"
LOCKDOWNS, YDAR
>> RepOVERNOO CONVICTION T I HID
IT'S
FIARLY IN S ERAGIN6,492 CASES
ONE WEEKPLED IMONTH.
IN JUST ONE WEEK FRO 15th
TO JULstFLORIDHAS S, AND I AGAI
LEADING THE NATION IN THE ER
OF NEWSEASON9 CASEDESANTIS S JU
JUST LIKE LAST YEAR.RE GOING TOE
HE RES JUL
AND THEN IT GOES
APRIL.orter: DOCTORS CONTAGIOUS
>> Reporr:
ALHIG FROM
DENT
>> THESEAC YOUR CHANSU IS GONE
FROM HIS TONE ST
>>ECOU'VE GOT A LOT LE IN PIO
WAXEPOETICALLY WEEKS AND WEEKS O
BE JUST LIKE NEW YORK.
WAIT TWO WEEKSA IS NGHEKS AWAY
FR TN'T
SO WE SUCCEEDED, AND THINK
PEOPLE JUST DON'T WANT T.ITTLE
TEN EKTHAT PRESS A BECAME AGLOBR
CAS  TIME.ORNIA, WITH IT'S ION,E
SELLING MERCHATHATDS  ISNTINUINO
"DON'TFLND
THE M GO
WITH A MA ON? OF FLORID
REATED.
AND THE STATE IS RECORDINGST NE
YET HE STANDS FIRM.
>> WE'VE NEVERAD ANY MANDATES T.
SUPPORTERS SIM. MASKDATES,  WASB
BUTHTYUTNDT IS FOR024 FOR ESIDET
SPECIAL
ADSISTANT  GEORGE W. BUSH, AND
COVID PANDEMICESANTIS IS
INSISTENATT GO BACK TO RESTRICT.
U
IS HERE?
>> IALLYIS.
GOOD I A GD AVE G CIRCLE OAD TOS
INTERNALERT HELPS HIM
NAVI AENALLY IN THE CONSERVATIV
AHEAD OIT.THAT'S ONE OF THE AS
POLLING 24 ELECTION, SECON TT
TRUMP.
LEAST ON NATIONAL STAGE. A STAD
IS RATHEANT WITH HEAH
OFFICIALS.
R E
MAND, AND HE WILL FREQUENTLY
ORS SUCCESS. SSCOTT,S AC
FIRST IN TWO STRAW POLLS
2024 IP IS D QUESTIONS ABOUT
, BUT HERE ARE
OUTSIDE VI HE'S BEEN
>> CRITICAL RACE THEORY IS
BALLTO  COURYAC
OTHER.
DIVISIVE, AND IT' IY LIOF
WHILE SOME OVER THE LASTR
HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
FUEM WRE
PROUD TO SAYDI
INER FAUCIISM.AND WETER OFF FO
DOING THAT
O
REN GHT, SCOTTIT'S CLEAR DESANT
SO.
RON  A VERY, VERY U DIDN'T PLAYT
SMART INTERNALOM FOR WHAT RUB T
ABOUT ITHETHE RACE GNOIN FDAITRI
, ING
'24.
PICK IF  RUNS AGAI 2024.
HE ALWS TRIES TOD  ANY TIMTH
THRN
BECAUSE, OF COURSE, OFMP.
>> I
THAT, HEK OFF LIKE
RO.
CEBE
IDERED.
BEGINNINGF I WAE
HIM.ENCAME OUT AS A
A AND MEMENT
HELPED HIM TREMENDSL>> MARK,E'ED
SUCH THAT HE.
DO DISNK DANO MYENNTWH
HE DID MAKROT SAID AUNTRUE TBUHS
IS.EV TS
F THPARTY. LITYS SLIPLI REPUBLIE
ALL TH
HINT,  OUTLETS, ANRTAINLY FROM .
WHERE IT'S GOIN IF HE DOES.
GO.
I WANT TO , ONE
WE H THIE
AUDIOM AN INTERVIEW  E BOOK "I N
FI."
S ABOUT UMP'S SPEECH ON
LET ME PLAY PART OF THIS FOR
THIS CONVERSATION.
THERE WAS A LO LHERO, MANY
PEOPLE.
THAT WAS A LOVING CROWD.
USHERED IN BY T
THE CAPITOL PO WERE USHERINGLE .
AT AELEVERON RT TO SHO BECAUSE O
BEEN RIGGED RE.
>> SO OT
DOES, EAUN
THWI
CALLIN OUT, CALLING OUT
THRIGGING, OF ? MEAN, MY VIEW IE
IT'S RON ANYTHING
ELSE, THICAN
INTOAMA AND SAY, JOE BIDEN
WAS THE LY ELECTED
BU TELL YOU WHYOTY
IFE  T HAT IS WHAT THEY WILLTO
PLATFO DBECOMES
RELITIGATING 2020.
KNOW, THIS ELTIARY WAS BAD, WE I
WHAT HAPPENED WAS WRON
ANT
GENERAL ELECTIOM
THINK YOU'RE GOING TO FACE A
RIDE